[Music]
hey there and welcome back to line uh i
have another example i want to show you
in another tutorial i want to teach you
guys um
our training series online
this is what it looks like
switch to loop real quick
so this is um
horizontal lines
moving across you know left
right to left
with a simple title added in so i kind
of created this to be like a title
sequence
part of the title sequence
but what's unique about this is this is
not
shape layers
moving
across the screen this is a totally
different way of approaching lines
uh in motion design inside of after
effects so
it's not what you think it is so that's
why i wanted to teach you this technique
it's pretty cool so
this is essentially what we're going to
recreate today
as you can tell from most of the
examples we do
nothing ends up looking exactly the same
sometimes it looks better sometimes it
looks worse but that's the joy
kind of the fun in
doing this is showing you what i created
to begin with and then
stepping back recreating it as i record
and show you guys
and see what we come up with so let's
get to it
okay the first thing we are going to do
here
is create a new composition 1920 by 1080
i went back from 2048
to 1080 but actually let's do this let's
do two
2048 by 1080. that one you just saw was
1920 but
this will work
and let's create a new solid
and let's call this
fractal line
and we'll make it
well
let's keep the color it is it's that
purple color from last time
um we're gonna go to uh
generate
nope
uh fractal noise
there we go
and we're going to change it from soft
linear to block
and we are going to
crank this way up
and this
down here
and let's crank this up even more
[Music]
and then let's go into transform and
turn off uniform scaling
we're going to make it pretty wide
here
and
turn off the sub
uh okay that'll work for now um so here
we've got just a checkerboard uh pattern
where it's just longer than it is
uh vertical
yeah
and let's turn down the complexity as
well
and we're actually going to go to effect
obsolete
luma key
and we're going to key out the darker
by a threshold of
one
so there you go we can see the key now
cool
okay and we're also going to um
we're going to make this comp way larger
let's make it like
3 000 something
and we're going to make this solid
the same size
there we go
and let's go ahead and we're going to
mask out
the center of
i don't know something like this
and we're gonna go ahead and pre-compose
this
and we're gonna call this
fractal free pc for pre-comp move all
attributes into a new composition
click okay
there we go
okay
so now we're going to go into um
transitions
and we're gonna do a card wipe
okay and
we're gonna crank the rows way up like
500 and something
and we're going to crank the columns
down to a one
i was going to crank up the card scale
and we are going to
camera position boom boom boom okay
okay so we're going to turn down the
transition complete and the transition
width to zero we're going to go into
position jitter we're going to crank
this up
that's about five
you can see the line's starting to
form here
uh jitter speed
jitter amount
jitter amount 13.
yeah
let's crank this up
and we're gonna do some timing
randomness of one
and you see it's all about playing with
the settings here
to get this to look
interesting
so let me go ahead and preview this and
show you we've got
so you can see here it's interesting
it's the lines are moving um all over
the place though right and we don't want
that so
uh the y jitter speed needs to be
cranked down to zero
and the z and now we've got the lines
are just moving
left
to right
they're still too fast so let's
turn this down to like
point one
and that's interesting but seeing in
here it's still moving way too fast so
how about
point zero one
okay that's much more interesting it's a
lot slower movement
but to i still feel like there's too
many lines going on here so the next
thing i'm going to do is i'm going to go
to transition again
and i'm going to select block dissolve
and we're going to crank the width up
actually let's turn this up to about 70
and just crank this width way up there
and this is without
and width
so you can see it really thins up the
lines
it makes them a little more interesting
so there we go we've got the lines
moving right to left
left to right
interesting movement let's go ahead and
make this a 3d layer
and
let's make
the main comp we're in
back to 2048
by 1080 so we have some room to work
with here
yeah okay
and let's add a new camera
one node camera again 35 millimeter sure
boom
and what i did here was i just set a
keyframe and i started
over in here and i started
lowering the frame
i don't want everything always just you
know perfectly centered up so
[Music]
i started lower here
went across
about here
and let's just make i like to make
things even so we'll do it at 2 2
seconds 12 frames we'll move forward 12
frames we'll go hold down shift
move the camera up
12 more frames
move it across
and then we'll continue with our move
all the way across
just like that
so let's see how this looks here
okay and there we go
it's previewing boom boom
interesting interesting so the only
thing that i don't like is how jerky
these keyframes are i'm going to right
click keyframe assistant easy's out
right click keyframe assistant easy ease
in
and the very center one keyframe
assistant easy ease
much smoother animation there cool
and i'm going to go ahead and add uh
some text
i'm not going to show you um
actually i will show you
let's do directed
by
and on a second layer we'll do
aka
let's just do ak
and we'll make these both 3d
and we're going to go ahead and i'm
actually going to parent aka to direct
it nope actually we're not going to do
that i'm going to go ahead and scale
down directed by
and this is using agents again from last
time i'm just going to switch to den
which is always my
pretty consistent
fallback font
i love it
and i'm going to direct it by just a
little smaller again
[Music]
over here and i'm going to parent aka 2
directed by so if i remove directed by
[Music]
it
will follow with it
quick uh tip here if i'm trying to line
things up i'll just go to show rulers
and then i'll just drag from the top
ruler down
line up
right here under aka
[Music]
and i'm just gonna
nudge down directed by
nudge up
ak
cool and i'll go back to few show guides
and turn it off because we're good to go
so now obviously aka and directed by are
too big shrinking them down
and all i did to
[Music]
bring these two in is i went to
uh
animation presets and i did a decoder
fade in
very simple
um and then i just
took the keyframes and i made them much
much quicker
and then i overlapped them so directed
by comes in
and then
aka
comes in
so that's the gist of it
so how did i make it look um
that much cooler let me show you here
so here's what it looks like at a rough
level
you know it's cool you know in itself
it's just um
rough
but like i said this is where you always
want to start you always want to um
start with something that
um
looks good to begin with and then we add
that polish on top of it to make it even
better so
that's what we're going to do here
so the first thing i'm going to do is
add some blur
into this and to do that i'm going to
create a new
uh let's see here let's do a new
composition
we're going to call it depth matte
depth map
make sure it's the same size our
composition yep
cool
and we're gonna do a new layer
new solid and we're gonna call this uh
depth
fractal
call it whatever you want
and to this we are going to apply
generate or sorry always go the wrong
place fractal noise noise and grain
fractal noise
uh basic soft linear yep
crank this down we're gonna transform
this way up
make it
very uncomplex
and then we're going to animate it and
that's super simple by using the
evolution so i'm going to keyframe the
evolution so i clicked there
got a keyframe here i'm going to go to
the end i'm just going to make it do 1
rotation
and you can see here that it's uh
slowly uh moving between black and white
right it's black and white we're gonna
use the black and white as our depth map
i do want to uh
feather it just a little bit more so
when i go to blur and sharpen i'm going
to do a fast box or i'll do a gaussian
blur actually
repeat edge pixels
crank it up
pretty high
so it's pretty subtle
a little bit more
so there we go
so now i've got a depth map okay
bring that depth map down to my
composition
it's down here i don't need to see it i
can turn it off
go ahead and lock it i'm going to create
a new
adjustment layer
and to this adjustment layer i'm going
to apply another blur which is a camera
lens blur okay
and under the blur map i'm going to
select layer
depth map
and i'm also going to crank this up
and let's just see if we're seeing
anything here
oh yeah that's too much
let's go down to 50.
maybe 25.
yeah that's okay
so right now it's not working for me
because it's got just uh too much blur
going on it's not uh divided up enough
so i'm going to go back into my depth
map here
and go into
sub settings and crank those up let's
see what that does
that doesn't do much
so that's starting to look a little bit
better
okay so there we go
there's the blur
it's moving around looks pretty good
directed by is still too big so i'm
gonna scale that down
it pretty tiny
i look at what i'm doing here is i'm
looking at the size of the lines in
relation to directed by aka and you
don't want aka to be like you know huge
all right you can either go two ways you
can either go overly large with these
tiny lines or you can go
uh smaller
you know that matches more of the size
of the scale of the lines which is what
i'm doing here
still want to play with that depth map
just a bit here
maybe a bit more
and there it's all about the
details right
so that's a lot of blur
that's pretty cool
okay so one thing i do want to change
here is i want to go back into my fraxel
comp here
and
i need some more gray
values in here
you can see by turning the luma key off
and on it's creating more
space in between the lines without luma
key it looks like they're just very very
long lines with luma key
they're more
spaced apart lines
so
so i like how this is starting to blur
now
starting to look a little more
interesting to me
turn the complexity up this is going to
get more complex over here which i don't
necessarily want that
it's just a little bit of complexity
maybe a little bit more
yeah i think that works for me
and then i also want to um
bring down the size of this which to do
that
i just have to bring down the size of my
mask
like so
one other thing i'm going to do here is
the transform properties
i'm going to make it a little bit longer
also a little bit taller so there should
be less lines
yeah they're not so
dense
that's cool
i like that a lot
okay so we're going to close that
unlock that
go back into here
[Music]
cool
add some effects
go up here do a new adjustment layer
uh i did use uh glint again on this one
and we're gonna change this to color
and
and maybe mess with the threshold just a
bit
and let's also mess with the hue shift
actually that's not
let's mess with the
blur glint
just a little bit of blur
maybe in there
i'm actually going to take the glint
below
there we go that's kind of cool
so i like how it's adding some color
here i'm also going to do my favorite
effect of as always the warp chroma
[Music]
boom
now this is just very subtle chromatic
aberration
with
without with
without actually going to drop it in
front of the glint
yeah that's pretty cool
so then i'm going to copy the warp
chroma
[Music]
and actually what i'm going to do here
is i'm going to take the two pieces of
type
i'm going to pre-compose them
call this
type
pre-cut
make that 3d and i'm gonna hit collapse
transformations
and boom there it is i'm gonna apply the
warp chroma to this
there we go
gives it kind of a greenish look that's
pretty cool
[Music]
this one's gonna turn out a little
different but i like it so then we're
going to do another um actually with
this effects light well let's do another
new adjustment layer at the very top of
everything
this will be called noise again
we need a background
as well
call this
background and it might be kind of cool
to do like a greenish
actually let me sample a color here
something really dark well maybe it's
blue okay let's drop it down
somewhere in there this is our
background
oh
nope i don't like that
solid settings
let's go even darker
i don't like that either
okay well we're going to leave the
background off for now we're gonna add
some noise
crank this up
yeah that's just not working for me
the noise with the background works so
what we're going to do here is we are
going to actually just
call this blur
we're going to lock that
under effects we're going to
take the glint
turn it off and we're going to add it
just to the
lines
yeah so we've got the same kind of look
there
and then we're going to add a another
new solid we're going to call this
mini grid
and to this we're going to go to
generate
uh
where we got grid and we're going to
make this puppy really small width and
height sliders
go three
by
five
and we need to turn down
we want this to be very very subtle
and
let's do this
let's try that let's change it to
transfer mode of add
and take it below
there actually let's take it all now
let's leave it up here let's just try
that how about point
one
yeah so see it it kind of gives it like
this um
tv look
without
with
okay so there you go so this one looks
totally or not totally but quite a bit
different than the other version um that
i showed you so i'm gonna give you guys
both versions to download you can
download
this version which we just did and you
can download the one i did previously
which looks a little more techy
it's got a little more effects added to
it for the coloring uh but dissect that
one as well and uh see which one you
like better i think they're both pretty
cool in their own right so
um yeah i hope you guys enjoyed uh this
week's lessons on lines
as always leave a comment below let me
know what you think if you learned
anything new um
yeah whatever
leave me a comment below let me know and
uh i will talk to you guys very very
soon see ya bye